condom et soyons confiants et en ce 24
décembre bien il sera d'abord question
du train de noël vous allez avoir un
aperçu de l'ensemble dans quelques
instants
pourquoi nous aurons des petits papiers
à la main parce que c'est extrêmement
compliqué oui partant de bruxelles via
lille arras et amiens pour paris qui
sera sa destination
notre train de noël sera conduit par
jean nohain et toute son équipe
habituelle qui proposeront des
distractions et des jeux pendant tout le
parcours c'est à dire à l'intérieur du
train aux voyageurs ces voyageurs et
bien ce seront essentiellement et des
grands-pères belge qui partiront en
quarts de bruxelles pendant que se
déroulera à paris marie-claude avec
leurs petits-enfants et ils arriveront
de cette façon ali mais par anticipation
si vous avez bien nous allons imaginer
que nous sommes le samedi 24 décembre et
il est 13h45 c'est à ce moment là que le
train de noël prend le départ de lille
voilà le départ est pris je dois ajouter
que le réalisateur c'est à dire
alexandre tartas et assurer la
participation d'un hélicoptère c'était
extrêmement compliqué comment
vouliez-vous pouvoir suivre le spectacle
à bord du train sans un relais
absolument indispensable donc tout cela
se déroulera dans le train et nous
allons de ce fait arriver maintenant à
arras
à